non moi c'est moi ce qui me gêne c'est
que j'ai l'impression qu'on nous
culpabilise de plus en plus et de
l'autre côté vous dit qu'on est tous
responsables mais au quotidien
donnez moi par exemple c'est quelque
chose qu'on devrait changer donc les
téléspectateurs comprennent parce que
effectivement la prise de conscience
vous souvenez avec rom qui a fait plus
de 8 millions de téléspectateurs à
l'époque sur france 2 là les audiences
soient un petit peu moins importante et
je crois savoir pourquoi c'est parce que
en fait on nous culpabilise surtout en
ce moment
et de l'autre côté on vois pas ce qu'on
peut changer au quotidien et chacun de
notre côté parce que quand les delphine
donne son exemple effectivement on de
pas eu deux pas des exemples ne pas
gâcher par exemple l'eau des choses
comme ça c'est des choses qu'on peut
faire également pour ce film j'ai
beaucoup de mal à le vendre
personne ne voulait le prendre parce que
c'était trop pessimiste aujourd'hui de
dire la vérité c'est d'être pessimiste
d'accord mais ouais on va tous mourir un
jour faut le savoir
on peut raconter ce que moi je suis que
le messager de ce que disent les
scientifiques
simplement j'ai alors voulu vous donner
des exemples allait arrêter de consommer
les viandes industrielles extrêmement
simple tous les coachs sont des millions
de cochons qu'on ait enfin sonné
il ya des gens qui ont pas les moyens de
cette fois arrêter avec ça non non non
attendez
non mais qui dit des choses c'est
possible les élevages leveaux regarde
quand tu d'accord manquer bon il ya des
gens qui peuvent pas médian qui peuvent
ok donc c'est plus cher a sombré prier
des paysans qui suit c'est tous les
jours parce qu'on paye le lait pas son
prix qu'on ne jette pas la pierre
masseret est ce que c'est normal c'est
une honte que les paysans ne peut pas
vivre ce qu'ils font un bon boulot il
faut les aider
autre chose j'ai arrêté après prendre
l'avion veut voter pour les politiques
qui mettent l'écologie au coeur de leur
programme mais pas les écouterons alors
on va par seconde et écolo qui ont alors
que les lions confiance dans les gens
qui nous dirigent c'est important c'est
chose sinon alors au lez lille est
vraiment les choses à faire aux
associations de bière bénévoles pour
aider les gens croire qu'on peut aimer
qu'on peut partager avec plus de
bienveillance regarder le monde de nous
sans cynisme et sans voilà sans
scepticisme en permanence croire aux
bonnes choses aujourd'hui il ya environ
un mois extrêmement méchant mais qui ont
fait quelque chose on savait tout sur
vous et vous et bien sûr les réseaux que
ça se passe chacun peut trouver ou est
ce qu'il peut faire quelque chose c'est
quand même pas très difficile
de réfléchir comment dépenser moins de
carbone